s est invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
nadia un trouble safsaf bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci d'être là
vous êtes
journaliste enfonce abandonné une
enquête auprès des enfants des rues
c'est votre dernier texte qui est publié
chez jean claude lattès dans la
collection la grenade de l'image que
l'on voit derrière nous a été prise
place de la bastille à paris ça fait une
dizaine de jours que plusieurs dizaines
de jeunes étrangers campent dans des
tentes bleues pour alerter sur leur
situation ils sont ce qu'on appelle dmn
a en france on aime les acronymes c'est
quoi
alors menacer un mineur non accompagné
avant on les appelait les mineurs isolés
étrangers il a aujourd'hui ces mineurs
non accompagnés et effectivement depuis
une dizaine de jours ils sont à la
bastille et moi ce qui me frappe c'est
le peu de journalistes qui se déplace
aussi pour communiquer avec eux et
discuter puisque je discute avec utopia
56 pour avoir des informations et
à organiser ça ça parait il ils ont très
peu de journalistes qui s'est déplacé on
a l'impression que c'est un sujet qui
mobilise pas pourtant en france on
devrait s'inquiéter de savoir qu'il ya
des enfants qui vivent dans la rue des
enfants mineurs
et menace d'un sigle derrière lequel se
cache d histoire singulière et plurielle
écrivez vous d'où viennent ces jeunes
cela et feu qui sont d'ailleurs dans
paris pourquoi et comment ils sont
arrivés jusque là comment sont ils
accueillis ou non accueilli précisément
c'est le sujet donc de ce livre auquel
vous avez consacré un an de travail que
vous avez campé dans le quartier de la
goutte d'or c'est un quartier populaire
dans le 18e arrondissement dans le nord
de paris pourquoi est ce que vous vous
êtes intéressé à ces jeunes et pourquoi
ces jeunes de la goutte d'or en
particulier mais j'avais envie de
comprendre comment aujourd'hui en france
en 2022 on accepte que des enfants
puissent errer dans la rue on a tous vu
un ces images qu'on avait été reprise
par les télévisions d'enfants présentés
comme délinquants pauli délinquants pour
les toxicomanes et j'avais envie d'aller
voir derrière cette image qu'est ce
qu'on en dise est réellement et ce que
j'ai vu c'est des jeunes qui avaient
envie de
d'autres choses qui rêvait d'autres
choses et c'est pas forcément cette
image de délinquance qui leur colle à la
peau dire qu'on aura collé l'étiquette
et on n'arrive plus à se défaire de
cette étiquette et de se rendre compte
que ce sont des enfants avant d'être des
migrants jusqu'à rappeler ça pour moi le
propos du livre c'est vraiment de
rappeler que ce sont d'abord des enfants
d'où viennent ces jeunes comment sont
ils arrivés en france comment ça se fait
qu'ils sont avec qu'ils sont sans
adultes autour d'eux sans leurs parents
alors il ya beaucoup de fantasmes
d'ailleurs là-dessus parce que les gens
imaginent que ce sont des réseaux qui se
met en place alors que c'est quand même
c'est moins linéaire que ça c'est
beaucoup d'enfants qui arrivent par
eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire qu'il monte en dx
se cachent dans des camions ils se
cachent dans des bateaux il arrive pas
il traverse le maroc l'espagne est avéré
particulièrement par mes dd jeanne qui
viennent plutôt dû plutôt du maghreb
voilà plutôt du maghreb du maroc
essentiellement maroc algérie très peu
tunisie mais en la tunisie passe par
l'italie mais beaucoup maroc et
algériens alors pourquoi barbès parce
que par baisse reste une terre d'accueil
une terre d'immigration il ya des
repères sociolinguistique il ya des
repères culturels donc pour eux c'est
plus facile d'arriver là-bas dans ce
quartier là en tout cas de combien
d'enfants on parlera pas forcément que
dans le xviiie et peut-être dans la
région ile de france qu'est la région où
il y a le plus d'arriver par an on parle
de milliers en fait dire que à la goutte
d'or ce serait une centaine savary assez
régulièrement parce qu'ils partent ils
font ils viennent mais en région
parisienne c'est plus d'une centaine et
plus d'un millier pardon à quoi ont
droit théoriquement ces enfants ces
jeunes à leur arrivée en france que dit
que dit la loi normalement ils ont le
droit à une protection c'est la
convention des droits de l'enfant
normalement ils ont droit à une mise à
l'abri et c'est pas tout à fait respecté
d'abord parce que les institutions sont
débordés ensuite
il ya un problème aussi je pense un
dysfonctionnement institutionnel entre
les différentes institutions entre les
départements l'état chacun se renvoie un
peu la balle et je pense qu en fait on
ne sait pas faire tout simplement on ne
sait pas on le maire du 18e de disette
de manière très intéressante dans vivre
c'est qu'au départ c'est un tout petit
groupe donc on s'inquiète pas forcément
puis le groupe grandit et ses îles ont
été alertés par les habitants et les
habitants qui disent attention là il
commence à y avoir un problème ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux ces gamins
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait parce qu'au
départ c'est la société civile jusqu'à
maintenant ont d'ailleurs c'est la
société civile qui pallie à ces
défaillances et c'est les habitants du
quartier au départ qui les nourrissent
qui les aident qu'il est ce qu'au bout
de cinq ans six ans tu sais quand même
six ans pour certains que la situation
s'éternise et donc ceni une vie pour les
riverains ni une vie pour ces enfants
parce que de ce que la loi a dit ce que
le droit d'y en théorie c'est que les
enfants quand ils arrivent ils doivent
être effectivement reçu là elles doivent
vous allez peut-être nous expliquer
éventuellement prouver leur minorité
avec des avec des techniques qui pose
question et ensuite effectivement
bénéficié d'un programme de soutien ou
en tout cas de mise à l'abri ce qui se
passe effectivement c'est que soit ils
ne sont pas dans le circuit officiel
soit il n'y a pas de place pour les
accueillir et là il se retrouve à la rue
alors normalement et effectivement ils
sont quand ils arrivent ils se
présentent au dispositif d'évaluation
des mineurs et laon ils vont être reçus
par des personnes qui vont évaluer leur
parcours et là où ce que disent les
associations c'est pas moi qui le dit
bien sûr moi je suis journaliste je
recueille ce que disent les associations
c'est que ces entretiens ne sont pas
mener comme ils devraient l'être veut
dire que quand on interroge un enfant
qui arrive d'un long périple qu'on me
pose des questions précises sur les
dates on lui demande à quel âge il est
parti on lui demande quel mois sur
quelle année il est à l'école avec quel
moment sa mère est morte comment et
quand ils ont mis deux ans pour arriver
en france par exemple bon je prends
l'exemple des africains sub sahariens
qui met deux ans pour arriver
en france il a 13 ans les dates c'est
compliqué et puis il ya tous les
stigmates de l'exil de traverser des
vivres des choses très difficiles et on
leur demande d'avoir une maturité dans
leurs réponses
d'adultes c'est à dire d'avoir un
discours structuré
précis alors qu'on nous dit que ce sont
des enfants et pour bénéficier je le
mets entre guillemets donc de cette mise
à l'abri qu on le comprend qu'il ne
concerne pas tous ces jeunes pour des
raisons diverses on leur demande donc de
prouver leur minorité grâce à une
technique je crois qu'il ya presque un
siècle c'est ça oui les tests osseux
souvent ces enfants n'ont pas de
documents officiels donc ce qu'on leur
reproche d'ailleurs et c'est ça aussi
que les associations pointent c'est
qu'on met toujours la responsabilité
de la défaillance de leur prise en
charge sur ses enfants c'est à dire
qu'en gros on leur dit qu'ils sont pas
pris en charge parce qu'ils ne font pas
l'effort pour être pris en charge donc
c'est un peu ça le cercle vicieux parce
que ils n'ont pas de documents pour
prouver leur identité donc ils ne
peuvent pas prouver l'orage donc on leur
dit vous mentez en fait il ya tout de
suite la suspicion du mensonge tirkel
pas cette présomption d'innocence elle
n'est pas respectée cette présomption
d'innocence de minorités n'est pas n'est
pas respectée on part du principe que la
france est assiégé on va le dire est que
si on veut à tout prix y rentrer et pour
ses enfants ceux qui parviennent à
arriver devant les bonnes instance il ya
des délais extrêmement longs entre
moment où les entends et au moment une
décision est prise éventuellement de les
placer ou de les aimer ces séries alors
après voilà je vais pas dresser un
tableau tout noir non plus il ya aussi
des ça marche aussi quand les choses se
mettent en place par moments et oui il y
a quand il ya un vrai suivi et des
enfants qui sortent de la rue qui sont
qui sont pris en charge mais c'est une
mine aux essais une minorité est ce
qu'ils ont ce qu'on veut quand je dis
nous c'est les associations encore une
fois c'est qu'elle réclame que ce
dispositif il soit ouvert à tous les
enfants et que vraiment on prenne en
charge cette présomption de minorités et
comprennent pas les tests osseux parce
que les tests osseux c'est qu'on va on
va regarder lost de l'enfant sociaux ont
tenté de déterminer son âge pour
déterminer son âge d'abord c'est des
pratiques qui font penser à d'autres
pratiques de la seconde guerre mondiale
donc moi ça me fait un peu tiquer et
ensuite ce sont des
pratiques qui ne sont pas en fia bhl
c'est ça merci chercher le mot en tout
cas pas complètement en fait il ya une
marge d'erreur de 2 ans et 2 ans est
énorme parce que si vous avez vous
prétendez vous avez 16 ans et que le
test osseux dit que vous avez 18 ans eh
bien vous n'êtes pas mis à l'abri et
puis en plus là aussi ça on parle de
protection de l'enfance mais même
aujourd'hui en france un enfant français
qui est placé à 18 ans en gros on lui
demande d'aller dehors sauf que les
associations elle réclame aussi pour ces
enfants là des dispositifs qui
permettent de les prendre en charge
jusqu'à au moins 21 ans parce qu'on sait
très bien que les enfants ont besoin de
saint céré
vous le disiez donc bon alaïa et les
situations sont différentes en fonction
des départements il ya une forte
pression en ile de france
donc ces enfants doivent en partie leur
salut à quelques associations dont vous
suivez notamment le travail dans ce
livre reste que les enfants qui sont
livrés même qui arrive dans la rue pour
différentes raisons sombre souvent dans
l'ain délinquance la toxicomanie voir
l'envers sens chronologique et là on est
dans un cercle vicieux vous dites que
dans les primo délinquants en détention
retrouve un taux d'enfants de 10 m et
n'a donc de mineurs non accompagnés
très élevé mais parce qu'on ne prend pas
en compte leur polytraumatismes et même
la défenseure des droits des enfants
l'avait dit que ou larvée on ne
retrouvait plus de lna qui sont
sanctionnés plus rapidement c'est à dire
que e.on a tolérance zéro pour eux de
dire que un autre enfant il y aurait un
rappel à la loi il y aurait on les
obligeraient il y aurait le principe des
dix kabylité j'en parle aussi dans le
livre c'est à dire qu'on ferait tout
pour insérer d'autres enfants mais ces
enfants-là systématiquement on va être
dans une réponse répressive qu'est ce
que le sort de ces enfants dit pour vous
de la politique d'accueil d'asile de la
france
ça m'a beaucoup
questionné mais même aussi sur ma
binationalité puisque j'ai la chance
d'avoir deux nationalités et de me dire
que finalement tout ne tient qu'à une
question de chance d'être née du bon
côté de la méditerranée et ils sont pour
eux sont nés du mauvais côté de la
méditerranée et je pense que les enfants
devraient être accueillis encore une
fois en respectant la présomption
d'innocence eux ils viennent la tête
plein de rêves vous avez dit présomption
d'innocence même présentation
d'aménorrhée peut il perdre justement le
lapsus mes yeux ils viennent avec je le
dis à un moment dans le livre aussi avec
leurs rêves en bandoulière c'est à dire
que on quitte jamais un endroit pour
pire on imagine toujours que ce sera
mieux ailleurs et donc eux ils viennent
en france parce qu'ils ont le sentiment
qu'ils n'ont pas ce qu'il faut au maroc
ou en algérie et que ici ils ont une
chance de s'insérer que ici vous avoir
une chance de faire une formation voilà
ils viennent pas en se disant je vais
aller en france il veut être délinquant
c'est pas du tout ça le projet le projet
c'est de se construire une vie meilleure
et qu'est ce qu'ils disent justement du
sort qui leur est réservé ceux à qui
vous avez parlé ils comprennent pas
parce que
ils ont l'impression qu'on leur a menti
qui se sont leurrés il n'imaginait pas
vivre dans la rue d'ailleurs ils mentent
souvent à leurs proches quand ils en ont
encore au maroc ou même à leurs amis ce
qui fait que d'autres viennent parce
qu'ils imaginent que tout se passe bien
il se met en scène en disant que tout va
bien le prennent en photo devant les
grands mots nîmes honneur c'est
intéressant vous raconter que tous ne
viennent pas d'un milieu social
forcément défavorisés au maghreb ils ont
des parcours de vie est très différent
qui les a qui les ont amenés à la france
mais n'ont pas forcément fui la misère
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
en tout cas pas tous non mais ou deux ça
peut être des situations
complexe familial comme des fugues en
france en vie il ya des enfants de
médecins qui fugue en france soyez quand
il ya des situations un peu familial
difficile des remariages veuvage
mésentente et puis il ya aussi le goût
de l'aventuré on n'en parle pas l'ampli
mais il ya aussi des gens il ya aussi
des voilà qui partent aussi parce qu'ils
ont envie de découvrir autre chose des
enfants qui nourrissent écrivez-vous le
fantasme d'un pays submergée par
l'immigration et la perte de son
identité
merci beaucoup à nadia a troublé assaf
d'être venu nous parler de ce livre dont
qui résonne donc avec notamment cette
manifestation qui a lieu encore ans je
crois à bastille à la place de la
bastille à paris sous l'égide de
l'association utopia 56 enfance
abandonnée une enquête auprès des
enfants des rues chez jean claude lattès
dans la très belle collection de la
grenade on aime beaucoup ici très bonne
journée à vous